a giant puppet of a little girl is on an
epic journey across europe the puppet
was created to raise awareness about the
problems facing millions of young
refugees around the world her trip
started in turkey in july she traveled
through half a dozen countries and now
has arrived in england elizabeth
elizabeth palmer walked with her in
london and shares her story
this is little moth
not so little actually 11 feet tall
trudging up in english channel beach
thanks to skilled puppeteers
she was created as a nine-year-old
syrian refugee girl searching for her
mother to focus attention on the plight
of asylum seekers
[Music]
the welcoming committee included school
kids
and the actor jude law
little amal is the project of good
chance theater and the handspring puppet
company
everywhere on her nearly 5 000 mile
journey she's drawn crowds
little amal is a big symbol of a
humanitarian crisis she stands for more
than 20 million refugees worldwide more
than half of which are kids under the
age of 18.
in the crowd we met one of the lucky
ones bayan why did you come here today
we come here because she remembered me
of my story because i have to leave
syria working to jordan and i am proud
she's now safely settled in britain
little amal set out in july from turkey
her track through eight countries was
designed to focus attention on the
desperation of refugees
most come to europe by sea almost 90 000
already this year packed into boats by
people smugglers who leave them to be
rescued or drown
twenty thousand made it to the uk alone
like this baby girl how old is this baby
40 days but refugees are not always so
welcome and neither was little amal
in greece anti-immigration protesters
pelted her with rocks
but there has been plenty of love too
from the pope in rome
[Music]
and from countless children who is she
you don't see her as a foreign
interloper but an abandoned child
perhaps even a friend
artistic director amir nazar zwabi says
that's the point the people that look at
her and start
telling themselves her story are
actively engaged
in empathy in compassion
and of course if you can do it to an
object
we hope you can do it to a fellow human
being
but can little amal really influence
europe's angry immigration politics will
we change reality
i don't know but it's our duty to try
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer london
wow so impactful and i think those
children seeing that and recognizing
you know more than 20 million refugees
their generation will look at it much
differently i think than than what we're
seeing right now when it comes to that
issue yeah for sure it's definitely
attention getting which is the point
yeah
impactful art a mere reflection of what
people are absolutely